No,
you get these stories now.
And then about these companies that
come out with claims that their brain
exercises can improve Iq and the
literature on that is damn dismal.
I can tell you it's that the holy grail
is to produce cognitive exercises that
produce a legitimate impact
on fluid intelligence and,
and like there's been a lot of work
done on that and the answer is so far is
that it doesn't work.
So what about the game?
What about the video gay bank?
I mean,
I know there has been a suggestion that
played video games actually improves at
least sub aspects of intelligence.
There's a couple of studies that
indicated that video games might improve
spatial intelligence,
but,
but
the problem,
and I think this is this is a critical
problem or apps and insoluble one,
or at least no one's solved it,
is that what you get is that if you,
if you exercise yourself
substantially on a given game,
you can radically accelerate
your performance in the game.
So you can get much better at
those specific skill share.
But you don't get generalization
across cognitive sets,
which is what you're really
hoping for it because I thought,
I thought that was the
claim from some of these.
They have shown some
increases in spatial Iq,
but there's not very many studies and
I would say they're far overbalanced by
the other side of the research equation,
which continually says,
and I've looked at this because I'm really
interested in the improvement of Iq.
I mean that's,
that's the holy grail in some sense.
And that,
and,
and uh,
the,
the overwhelming preponderance of
evidence suggests that you don't get
generalization outside the narrow domain.
Now why that is,
and even this,
it's even worse.
Hey,
because you might say,
well,
imagine that you could take five
different domains of intelligence still
associated type with g and you had
people practice routines in all five
dimensions.
Maybe you'd get generalization
under those circumstances.
And the,
the,
the results of the research
attempting that indicate that no,
as soon as you move away from
those specific practice instances,
you don't get generalization.
So I guess it's,
I guess it's subways.
Some of this is to be expected from
the consideration that everything is an
allocation problem with it
within the body at Bray into um,
that,
you know,
by a large
an improvement blood domain tends to be
bought at the expense of something else.
Uh,
yeah,
just that.
Right.
And then conscientiousness,
I can tell you some research we've done.
That's cool.
Although we haven't been able to
demonstrate that it's actually improved.
Conscientiousness,
the first thing to note about
conscientiousness is that
no one understands it at
all,
especially the industriousness element.
There's no plausible biological,
psychological neurophysiological or
animal models for conscientiousness.
All we've got is self reports.
We can't even find tasks that
conscientious people do better.
It's unbelievable.
But um,
blue self reports really awesome.
Well you can get reports from
teachers and parents and so forth,
but it's all human report.
She only way we can measure
it and we didn't know.
Like in my lab we probably tried 200
tasks trying to find something that
conscientiousness,
conscientious people do better.
No luck.
We can derive it from linguistic analysis
of verbal output now to some degree.
But that's still,
that's not a task,
you know.
So now we,
we produced a series of programs called
the self authoring suite and one of
them,
the future authoring program to writing
program that helps people lay out their
plans for the future in,
in detail.
So they have to consider their,
um,
their intimate relationships,
their career goals,
their educational goals,
their use of time outside work,
their plans to maintain mental and
physical health or their use of drugs and
alcohol.
They have to write for 15 minutes about
what kind of life they'd like to have if
they were taking care of themselves
three to five years in the future.
And then to write for the same amount
of time about how terrible their life
could be if all their
bad habits took control.
Okay.
And then they have to turn the pause
division into an implementable plan.
And we've managed to improve their college
grades by about 20% and dropout there
drug dropped their dropout rate by about
25% over about 10,000 students now.
But you know,
we tried to see if that was mediated by
an improvement and conscientiousness and
there was no evidence for that.
Now what it was mediated by was number
of words written during the exercise.
So it turns out that thinking
more about your future helps,
the more you think about it,
the more it helps.
And maybe that,
you know,
maybe that would translate
into an improvement in
conscientiousness across time.
But um,
there haven't been any credible studies
that I know of indicating that there are
exercises that can be done
to improve conscientiousness.
So that's also,
you know,
troublesome and worrisome because that
would be a nice thing to be able to do
content.
I mean,
I haven't thought much about it and I
don't know much about the literature and
cut yet just this as a trait.
But the word seems to connote to me as
an ordinary English speaker has a strong
social element to it as well.
It's kind of like a country yet just
person is somebody who doesn't forget his
obligations.
Your index of conscientiousness
and a university professor is,
you know,
somebody has asked you to write them
a reference letter for getting into
graduate school or whatever.
Do you actually prioritize and get the
Dab to think dotted Tibor is there some
risks that you'll just forget about it
and shove it to them somewhere else?
Um,
I imagine cut,
she had just,
this is having a strong element of,
of attentiveness to social obligation
and to the wellbeing of others as it is
defined in the personality.
Literature doesn't have any of that.
Well
I would,
I would say not so much attention to the
wellbeing of others because that's more
trait agreeableness.
Okay.
That's more than maternal dimension.
But there's definitely a massive
effect of social obligation,
which is part of the reason why
conservatives tend to be hired
conscientiousness,
the liberals,
but it's not well being of others.
It's duty.
And so the,
the,
the conscientious types may form
and maintain social contracts.
Yes.
They implement their plans.
Yup.
And they seem to feel shame
and self contempt when they,
when they fail to live up
to their social obligations.
And so that's another thing
that's interesting about
the income redistribution
idea because it's conceivable to me that
conscientious people would hate that
because conscientious
people do very badly.
For example,
if they're on,
if they're laid off from work,
even if it's not their fault,
they still take themselves
apart for their failure.
So and so conscientious
people in particular seem
to find in activity without
productivity,
highly aversive and adverse if enough
to really cause them in all major health
problems.
So
yeah,
that could,
that brings us back to what we
were discussing a little while ago,
the problem of
hub,
ensuring that large numbers people have
access to BD goof all work in an age at
which it is more and
more the case that uh,
the big components of the economy of our
blue bag away with very few employees,
I don't know.
I that's going to continue.
That's probably going to ask away or
back to that same topic to some extent.
Yes.
But again,
I,
I mean I think,
I think any inequality of opportunity
is sort of the bottom are bedrock of any
quality.
Yeah.
Having its impacts upon us.
It's,
it's certainly the bond,
but bedrock of,
of why we should care about it.
Odd moral and social justice.
Grouts it's like,
well why should people who,
okay,
why should [inaudible] birthright affect
the opportunity is available to what
and
well,
it's also with social catastrophe because
hypothetically you want to set up a
society so that whatever someone has
to offer is maximally offerable to the
community because otherwise
the community loses.
Yes.
Now it seems to be,
I mean,
I think one of the great examples of that,
although I don't think this
accounts for all of it,
is that the relationship between the
provision of women's rights by countries
and their economic productivity
is staggeringly high.
So I think that also has to do with o
openness in general to transformation and
change with,
with,
with the provision of women's
rights being an index of that.
But nonetheless,
it's a great predictor of the
eventual economic success.
Well,
partly it had ducks and partly perhaps
bar more direct effect that after all,
it slightly over half the population,
um,
maybe their talents are better utilized.
Um,
that's certainly what we would hope.
And I think,
I think,
as you said,
I think the evidence
at least suggests that.
So,
okay,
so let me recapitulate,
because we should probably fold this up.
And so,
so.